في السادس من كانون الثاني (يناير) عندما كانت العاصمة الأمريكية
تتعرض للهجوم ، بدأ بعض موظفي فيسبوك
في التفكير في الدور الذي
قد تلعبه شركتهم في تأجيج
الأكاذيب التي أدت إلى التمرد ، وأشار أحد
الموظفين إلى أن فيسبوك قد استرضت
الرئيس آنذاك دونالد ترامب لفترة
طويلة تعود إلى عام 2015  . دونالد جي ترامب
يدعو إلى
إغلاق
تام وكامل للمسلمين الذين يدخلون الولايات المتحدة
ولا ينسون أبدًا اليوم الذي دعا فيه ترامب إلى
حظر دخول المسلمين إلى الولايات المتحدة ،
كتب أحد موظفي فيسبوك ردًا على مسؤول
تنفيذي على فيسبوك في السادس من كانون الثاني (يناير)
قررنا أنه انتهك
سياساتنا ومع ذلك فقد تجاوزنا السياسة بشكل صريح ولم نحذف
الفيديو ،
فهناك خط مستقيم يمكن
رسمه من ذلك اليوم إلى اليوم
لن يحكم علينا التاريخ بلطف ، فنحن لا
نتحقق من الإعلانات السياسية ولا نفعل ذلك  افعل ذلك
لمساعدة السياسيين ولكن لأننا نعتقد
أن الناس يجب أن يكونوا قادرين على أن يروا
بأنفسهم ما يقوله السياسيون
واجه الرئيس التنفيذي لفيسبوك مارك زوكربيرج
انتقادات شديدة  من الديمقراطيين في عام 2019
عندما قال إن فيسبوك لن يتحقق من حقيقة
السياسيين مما يسمح لأشخاص مثل
ترامب بالدفع لنشر الأكاذيب المستهدفة
على المنصة ، كشفت وثائق فيسبوك الداخلية المسربة
أن أبحاث الشركة الخاصة أظهرت أن الناس يثقون في
المعلومات التي يشاركها السياسيون أكثر
من المستخدمين العاديين الذين يتشاركون السياسيين.
حتى أن المعلومات الخاطئة التي
يمكن تصديقها على موقع facebook قامت بتشغيل مجموعة مركزة
من المستخدمين في شيكاغو وفقًا
للوثائق المسربة التي أخبرنا خلالها الأشخاص
أن Facebook
يتحمل مسؤولية أكبر عن تصنيف المحتوى الخاطئ الذي
يشاركه القادة السياسيون أكثر
مما يتحمله المستخدمون العاديون ولكن لا يزال
المديرون التنفيذيون للشركة يقفون
بقرارهم عدم التحقق من
صحة السياسيين ، وفي الصيف الماضي عندما رفض زوكربيرج
التصرف بناءً على منشور رابحة ، فإن الدوس
والنهب في مينيابوليس سيؤدي إلى
إطلاق النار على الموظفين ، مما يدفع شخصًا واحدًا على الأقل إلى
مغادرة الشركة ، فلماذا تركت الشركة؟
رأينا عدة مرات الآن أن العلامة
لا تدعم أميره  أخبرنا iples zuck
مرارًا وتكرارًا أنه
لن يتم التسامح مع الدعوات إلى العنف على
المنصة حتى لو كانت من قبل
رئيس الولايات المتحدة ، أشارت
مذكرة داخلية على Facebook في أغسطس 2020
إلى أن اتخاذ قرار Facebook بشأن
سياسة المحتوى يتأثر بشكل روتيني
بالاعتبارات السياسية
تم تسريب المستندات من قبل
المخبر عن المخالفات على موقع فيسبوك فرانسيس هوغن الذي بدأ لأول مرة
في تقديم المستندات إلى
جريدة وول ستريت في وقت سابق من هذا العام ،
وقد قدم هوجين شكوى بشأن الشركة
إلى الجزء الثاني من أحد
إفصاحات هذا المبلغ للأمين
عن هذه الفكرة حول هذه الفكرة القائلة بأن  فريق العمل في
facebook الذي يعمل مع الحكومات بشكل
أساسي ليحافظ
على مشاركة الحكومات في قرارات الإشراف على المحتوى
، ومن أحد
المستندات الداخلية الخاصة بفيسبوك ، كتب أحد الموظفين
أن اتخاذ قرار فيسبوك بشأن
سياسة المحتوى يتأثر بشكل روتيني
بالاعتبارات السياسية إذا كان بإمكانك
التوضيح فقط  هذا بالنسبة إلينا قليلاً
هذا أمر لا يصدق  قضية مهمة
لدى فيسبوك مهندسين يركزون
على كيفية جعل المنصة آمنة
وسيقوم فريق السياسة العامة بتقييم ذلك
ويقرر ما إذا كان هذا سيؤدي إلى إزعاج
قوى سياسية معينة وهل سيشتكون من
أننا نحاول فرض الرقابة عليهم ،
وهذا أمر لا يصدق  الحساسية للمنظور
السياسي
تثير إحباطًا هائلاً
داخل الشركة ، وهذا ما
تكشفه الوثائق عن هؤلاء المهندسين قائلين: دعونا نقوم
بعملنا ، ونتوقف عن التلاعب بما
نفعله لإبقاء اثنين من السياسيين سعداء
، والأمر المدهش هنا هو أن
نرى الطريقة التي كان بها فيسبوك.  لعبت مثل
الكمان
خاصة من قبل اليمين المحافظ